speed speeding it's being spit good she
won
she was it right from the outset that
you cast her or when I when I first
started to play dota 2 I just wanted to
play dota 2 and just don't do anything
else at all dota wasn't really specific
like conscious choice for me I used to
play Warcraft 3 and Frozen Throne and
play all the fun maps on battlenet then
and dota was then one of the games that
we often played and then I grew from
well from Frozen Throne world Warcraft
came out and started playing would work
out full-time for a very long time and
then I got my daughter to bed icky which
I only got in the mail like only applied
for that and aux over even after ti1 I
didn't know even know Tia won what's
going on when it was happening but and I
didn't really know anything about
eSports at the time either apart from
maybe some arena games for World of
Warcraft but I just started playing dota
2 and I would just fell in love with it
oh yeah I ended up going to the
International - I think I got I got I
got I got still it could talk to me like
hey there's a chance that we can get you
to the International to
I'm sure whatever if you say so I mean I
didn't really believe that start and
then I think two or three weeks in
advance I got aleus you're going and I
was going with ghost gamers and they
sent me there as an interviewer and
never done any interviews in my entire
career anywhere at all and that was it
was nerve-racking my first interview I
think many people will remember that
because it was an interview with sample
437 and singsing where one for 370 of
the seriously dancers and 16 gave
answers that basically only says to
masturbate that was my first experience
as an interviewer so how are you
spending your time in Seattle so far if
you're not gaming masturbating sorry
masturbating but it was it was a really
awesome experience di2 was really really
humbling actually yeah it was awesome
I think ti4 was the first Ti where I
thought well even if I don't get to work
at this ti I will still continue
in DotA 2 rather than having to go look
for for a normal job for the club so I
think that's the time when when I made
it when I felt like like yes I actually
did it I made this
hi everybody I'm here with sugar here
with Cheever we're sitting here with
Seaver here with Cheever are you doing
today I'm doing really great thank you
I'm here with Seaver Cheever tell us
what it's like being the most popular
female caster and all of dota 2 I like
playing with no fear those three kind of
shining examples for that kind of play
to be honest everybody is playing
without fear apart from eg I had to say
it I'm sorry that's a good one
I liked it from from ti4 I was I was
only casting up until ti4 didn't do
anything else but cast basically and
then when TF work came around I got
asked like hey do you want to do some
some group stage panelists and sure I'll
be on the panel for for group stages
because I mean yeah that was my first
invite to t I'm not gonna say no times
Rock be kidding
so I went to ti-ti through tier 4 is
that in the panel respectable first day
James like hey you want to open the
shelter for the money sure never host
anything but you know I don't know why I
said yes but I did it anyways and it was
it was there's a lot of fun could've
done what could have gone better if I
think bangs like what done things
differently but that was that was insane
and then obviously making it a ti5 as
well and being a being a host for the
dream League as well over the last two
seasons three seasons actually has been
amazing and it's just it's yeah it's
kind of weird to think that that's my
life now
you